been real quiet offensively in the
second half
under two
green is in a torture chamber and
outside it goes curry three
another one
40 points for curry another turnover by
golden state way outside 40-footer right
wow
paul george
they couldn't call up because they
didn't have him
curry
followed by man outside wiggins on top
green and
it's back to steph
[Applause]
underneath
[Applause]
seconds to go
and with that three even if curry
which you probably will make both of
these with five seconds left you could
still go the length of the court of your
clippers and tie this ball game up man
just got the foul third on him we walk
to the other end
here comes the question now if you're
steve kerr
curry makes both of these and put them
up by three
do you fall quickly and make this a
free-throw
because the clippers have to go the
length of the court
[Applause]
warriors a couple timeouts and as you
said the clippers are out
will be a blind with
43 points a perfect three or three from
the strike
[Applause]
oh they're icing they're all player in
this building
not that it worries stephen curry this
is 91 from the wine
[Applause]
i would love to see a great free throw
shootout we forgot a name that would be
pretty good feed ash from the free-throw
line as well
[Applause]
will come in
[Applause]
deficit now two maybe three
now look this is
what flippers are trying to do they did
this at the end of the first half it's
called the home run play where they're
going to throw at the length of the
court
to zubats and he's going to shuttle it
either left or right to try to find a
shooter who's going to be streaking
if you're kavani as soon as zoo watch
catch the ball i'll grab them and wrap
them up send them to the free-throw line
[Applause]
three-point lead
no kapoor time-outs four-way seven
zoobots
shoved whistle looney pitch up the bow
that's exactly what he did you foul him
right on the catch
now if you're
tyler this is the important thing you've
got to make the first one that's the
most important make now you're down to
you purposely miss the second one
and try to get it spin
shoebox tonight from the line 5 8
what season 79
but you have to make first for this to
work
okay now you purposely missed this one
and even the guards that are out front
have to crash the board
you're looking for a tip in here to try
to sit in this the overtime
man has come in
for canal and shoot the ball high
so it hits the rim a couple times
[Applause]